what are you gonna do
Eureka that one looks good
I need a knife
Gwen Stefani and Blake Shelton go
foraging for fungi we're pretty excited
the couple enjoyed a unique date
trekking into the woods to look for
mushrooms
I don't want
you okay there's so many mushrooms
around us right now that I've never even
seen anything like this okay stop watch
me not be able to find him okay
they're right here
Gwen made a mini movie out of the
experience on Instagram including the
moment she discovered the mushrooms were
well oh my gosh like they're everywhere
I mean oh my God
[Music]
are they overgrown though
the lovebirds gathered up all their
findings and took them back to the house
where Chef Blake got down to business we
all cook Blake likes to experiment we
love making the memories the couple also
cut some flowering branches which they
put in a vase I mean that was some of my
best work you know and then Casey did
you did to the couple's
track happy anyway
[Music]
[Applause]
and it seems like these two really are
happy anywhere as long as they're
together oh my gosh Blake they're
everywhere Blake recently kicked off his
final season as a coach on NBC's The
Voice and is looking forward to spending
more time at home with his leading lady
and her three kiddos Kingston Zuma and
Apollo has it hit you yet that your time
on The Voice is coming to an end I don't
think it's really going to hit me until
uh the the last episode it's probably
going to be an emotional night that last
night I mean my God it's been 23 see 12
years it's unbelievable it's the all the
life that's happened and and I met my
wife on there like he said Blake met
Gwen on the show in 2014 and the two
went on to tie the knot in 2021. I'm
just so proud of him I mean he's brought
so much joy he's so talented and now
that they're nearly two years in seems
Blake's really leaning into being a fun
guy get it Eureka
foreign